think I loop swing home the acting
returning officer at election held on
the 8th of May 2017 to elect an Envy for
the Darlington parliamentary
constituency do hereby declare and give
notice that the total number of votes
given to each candidate was as followed
follows BRAC Kevin John UK Independence
Party 1180 Chaffin Jennifer commonly
known as Jenny Chapman Labour Party
22600 lady won
[Applause]
Carrie Anne Murray Liberal Democrat 1031
cut person
Peter Malcolm the Conservative Party
19400 and one Smid Kurt Matthew Charles
Green Party candidate 524 if I hereby
give public notice that Jenny Chapman is
duly elected as a member of parliament
for the darkness
[Applause]
the total number of votes cast across
the darlington six you see was
forty-four thousand eight hundred and
ninety-six the total number of ballot
papers rejected with 79 thank you
[Applause]